other second question do you think that
men ever fall in love with side chick
very good question and this is a long
and in-depth answer but it's a good
question let me peel my Clementine but
um no but it's a good question where is
too far I think publicly disrespecting
is too far so like you'll you'll notice
let's check the Moscow G all right let's
take an oligar billionaire from Moscow
he has his wife he has the girls he's in
the club with the girls who's in the
club with what didn't [__] dare
message his wife they wouldn't dare step
out of line like they know their place
right so if there's a hierarchy and they
know their place that's one way of doing
it
spending money on a girl certainly yeah
because men show love primarily through
our through our hard work not just
through our resource but through our
hard work if you take a man who's not
particularly Rich he shows his wife love
by getting up every day going to work
nine to five working his ass off paying
those bills that's how he shows love
that's why he does it for his wife and
his children most men around here
working [__] jobs carrying trash
they're doing that to show love so show
giving money yeah that would be a far
more scary indicator than just sex